[Music]
besides some small islands roundabout
britain
there is also a large island which
stretches parallel to britain on the
north
its breadth being greater than its
length
concerning this island i have nothing
certain to tell
except that its inhabitants are more
savage than the britons
since they are man-eaters as well as
heavy eaters
and since further they it an honorable
thing
when their fathers die to devour them
and openly have intercourse not only
with the other women
but also with their mothers and sisters
but i am saying this only with the
understanding that i have no
trustworthy witnesses for it and yet as
for the matter of man eating that is
said to be a custom of the scythians
and in cases of necessity forced by
sieges
the kelty the iberians and several other
peoples are said to have practiced it
concerning fuel our historical
information is still more uncertain
on account of its outside position for
fuel of all the countries that are named
is set
farthest north unless that the things
which pythagoras told us about thule as
well as the other places
in that part of the world have indeed
been fabricated by him
we have clear evidence from the
districts that are known to us for in
most cases he has falsified them as i've
already said before and
hence he's obviously more false
concerning the districts which have
been placed outside the inhabited world
and yet if judged by the science of the
celestial phenomena and by mathematical
theory
he might possibly seem to have made
adequate use of the facts
as regard the people who live close to
the frozen
zone when he says that of the animals
and domesticated fruits there is an
utter dearth of some and the scarcity of
the others
and that the people live on millet and
other herbs and on fruit
and roots and where there are grain and
honey the people get their beverage
also from them as for the grain he says
since they have no pure sunshine
they pound it out in large storehouses
after first gathering in the ears
thither for the threshing
floors become useless because of the
lack of sunshine
and because of the rains
[Music]
and pythius by whom many have been
misled
for after asserting that he traveled
over the whole of britain that was
accessible
pythius reported that the coastline of
the island was more than
40 000 stadia and added his story about
fuel and about those regions in which
there was no longer either land
properly so-called or sea or
air but a kind of substance concreted
from
all these elements resembling a sea
lungs a thing in which he says the earth
the sea
and all the elements are held in
suspension and this is a sort of bond to
hold it all together
which you can neither walk nor sail upon
now as for this thing that resembles the
sea lungs he says that he saw it himself
but that all the rest he tells from
hearsay
you